china unlike our country doesn't really
have a judicial system
where the companies get to debate or
present their position the chinese
government can change the rules at any
time
and we were living under a mirage where
we thought they wouldn't
we thought they would handle hong kong
with
a delicate hand we thought they would be
open
to cultural products like our movies and
music
and we thought they'd have an open mind
to democracy and freedom of speech and
newspapers
and it was all trending in the right
direction
and that our great engagement the great
engagement of the past two decades
us investing in factories there and
creating the iphone there
as well as them doing promotions
with the nba our movies making their way
into china we thought all of this was
heading in the right direction
and then we saw them trample over human
rights in hong kong
put three million uyghurs in jail and
start the great unraveling
of their entrepreneurial movement so
we've covered the ccp crackdown for the
last couple of weeks here as we move to
doing a little bit of news before uh we
do interviews on the podcast
and so let's cover some of the moves and
really
today 10 cent which is an incredible
conglomerate
in china that owns many different
companies and has investments in many
american companies
is now trading at 56 a share it's down
20
over the past three days and down almost
50 percent from its february high of 99
a share they've lost 150 billion dollars
in market cap over the past three days
basically they lost a coin base and an
airbnb
in a couple of days in terms of market
cap this is
a very serious situation and it's tanky
for a couple of reasons number one
the ccp ordered 10 cent to end exclusive
music licensing deals with record labels
around the world
according to the bbc so china is
cracking down on 10 cents music rights
monopoly if you don't know uh and i
didn't before i read the story tencent
bought china music corporation in 2016
giving it
the rights to more than 80 percent of
all music tracks in the chinese market
and according to china's state
administration of market regulation
every week we learn about a new
governing body in china
this is called samr sammer this was an
unfair advantage
over its rivals and so thinking about
that for a second
we're sitting here talking about the
different frameworks for antitrust we're
having a grand debate about it over the
last
decade is big tech getting too big are
they helping consumers are they hurting
consumers
and is there any kind of angle to stop
them from getting bigger
and is that in our best interest or not
we're having this like really
vibrant debate across administrations
across
political lines in the private sector in
the media it's fantastic
is a really vibrant democracy where you
can debate these things
but not in china from the bbc article
here's the quote the company and its
affiliated businesses
have been told they can no longer engage
in exclusive deals over music rights
and must dissolve any existing arenas
within 30 days this would be the
equivalent of
our government biden just saying you
know what i'm gonna send
you know the ftc the fcc whoever over to
google over to apple and say you know
what yeah you can't put
google flights at the top of your search
results anymore in fact
you can't have google flights just take
it out of the product or
going to apple and saying you know what
your deal with google for exclusive
search on apple iphones
yeah that's canceled and it's got to be
canceled within 30 days there's no
recourse here for these companies the
recourse is if you don't do it
you go to jail and get re-educated
that's basically what happens is you
disappear
so for people who were scared about
china
as our adversary and our contemporary
and that really is the big picture
should we be concerned about this or
should is this actually a win for the
west i
in a way think this is a win for the
west because now china is saying
any success you have we can take away
from you and i think that makes it
uh very untenable for investors from
around the world to invest in china
which they've been coveting for a long
time so
china's now taking away the ability for
americans to invest in these companies
or anybody around the world the saudis
whoever
who wants to play in a casino where they
can change
the rules and all of a sudden queens are
stronger than aces and
aces are weaker than kings i mean they
basically just shuffled the deck and
just changed
all the rules uh in addition to that
tencent also has a large investment
in the education industry in china which
is a booming space with lots of
companies because
the chinese are so focused on education
and people are willing to pay for it
and uh this chinese education space has
just been decimated
we started talking about this on friday
the ccp is banning companies that teach
school curriculum subjects for making
profits raising capital or listing on
foreign stock exchanges
so let's pause for a second there
imagine in america we said you know what
that test prep company or that after
school
kumon i think it's after school uh math
classes or
the princeton review coaching you on
your
uh gmats or your sats all that
now illegal you cannot make a profit
from that
and any companies are now non-profits i
mean and then how do you unravel that if
these companies went public
and they raised money from the private
sector do those people
just lose their investment what happens
to all those assets
maybe they bought a bunch of computers
they have cash in the bank do they buy
the shares back and then shut down
there is no orderly process here this is
happening
at an alarming pace it's happening at an
alarming pace
and the chinese government is a really
well thought out considered
organization they are thinking in
centuries
not quarters so they're
throwing away massive amounts of wealth
and influence on a global basis
why what is going on here and that
that's really the question
we need uh to answer now tencent owns a
20
stake in this chinese live touring app
uh which is called uanfudao which was
valued at over 15 billion in october of
2020.
ooan uh had raised 4 billion from
investors
and 10 cent stake is worth over 3
billion or i should say was worth over 3
million
and now it could be worth zero dollars
according to the financial times other
big players in china's education
industry blackrock
valley gifford sequoia china and
softbank
they're all now i guess going to have to
figure out what do they own and and what
are their lp's own
so speaking of softbank they suffered a
4 billion loss on their dd position
following the ccp
removing dd from the app store for a
cyber security review
that meant that new users couldn't use
the product
softbank owns 20 of dd and their stake
was worth 12 billion at the time of the
dd ipo
and after china's cyber security review
and rumors of dd's pending
punishment softbank stake is now worth 7
billion so this is having ramifications
now you have
china and saudi arabia which is the big
backer of softbank
now they are getting penalized for
what's going on
in beijing and with zha jingping like
what's exactly happening here this is
going to result in a lot of phone calls
from people's
whose bank accounts are being impacted
and china
obviously knows that tick tocks pairing
company bike dance they had recently
hired 10 000 employees according to the
information to work on education
projects
because it's such a huge opportunity and
now
they are in danger of basically having
to let those employees go or reassign
them
according to the article here's the
quote some bike dance employees who work
on the company's tutoring apps are
already asking
around for other job opportunities
outside of education because of concerns
that beijing's crackdown could force
many services to shut down so plans
are changing fast in china as i said in
my piece from 2016 five years ago
it's a rigged casino it's opaque and you
have no recourse if you're betting over
there you're taking a lot of risk
you know that going in it's kind of like
going into a card game
in you know hollywood run by a bunch of
cd characters i used to get invited to
these kind of crazy games molly's game
etc and who knows if molly's game was
corrupt or not
i never played in it but i was invited a
bunch of times
who knows if people were playing from
the same chip stack
right you could have all of this
collusion going on and you would never
ever know and that is the challenge here
uh
you're going into a market where there
isn't the rule of law where there isn't
a legal system
every startup needs to ensure they own
their intellectual property or ip for
short
and that starts with filing your
trademark i have
been filing trademarks for 30 years
and i know what i'm talking about it's
one of those things that people forget
to do
or they put at the bottom of their list
and i understand that it's a pain in the
neck
but it is not a pain in the neck anymore
if you don't know where to start
look no further than brain base file
it's a clean
simple and automated trademark filing
platform
that gives anybody the ability to
protect their best ideas
there is no need to spend thousands of
dollars on lawyers
to file your trademark for you no now
you can do everything yourself
in just a few easy steps brain based
file gives you
goods and services recommendations using
ai so you can avoid the back and forth
with the us patent and trademark office
uspto and you can eliminate human
error they also offer full transparency
into the uspto process with step-by-step
notifications
and real-time updates on your trademarks
approval this is a process folks
so save a ton of money just head to
brainbase.com
twist and enter the code twist at
checkout to file your first trademark
now
for just 169 that's a 15
discount that's right brainbase.com
twist and enter the code twist
at checkout to file your first trademark
now for just 169 dollars